bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux la nouvelle de ce mois
d'octobre la Paléo news de ce mois
d'octobre 2022 cette évidemment en ce 3
octobre
l'Académie du Nobel a décerné le Prix
Nobel de médecine au Paléo anthropologue
vanter pabo de l'Institut Max Planck de
recherche paléont paléoanthropologique
de Leipzig pour ses découvertes sur les
hominés éteints et sur l'évolution
humaine c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire qu'un paléontologue reçoit un
prix Nobel donc voilà bravo bravo à
vente et pas beau pour cette gigantesque
carrière je vais vous mettre la photo de
vente et pas beau le voilà
c'est un visage que vous avez forcément
vu dans un documentaire quelque part si
vous vous intéressez un tant soit peu à
l'évolution humaine il est le
il est le grand instigateur on va dire
de du séquençage du génome de Néandertal
en 2010 il y a eu cette exploit
extraordinaire qui a été le séquençage
complet de d'une espèce éteinte l'homme
de Néandertal le homo Néandertal en 6
c'était se vantait pas beau et son
équipe évidemment
le prix Nobel est décerné au personnage
mais c'est l'équipe évidemment qui a
derrière qui est aussi qui est aussi
évidemment à l'honneur quand on desserre
un imprimobel donc c'était ce vanter pas
beau et son équipe pour le séquençage de
la génétique de du génome de l'homme de
Néandertal donc tout ce que vous avez pu
voir dans la littérature depuis 2010 sur
les possibles hybridation entre humains
et Néandertal c'est lui voilà c'est lui
il y a son odeur dessus s'il y a pas son
nom dessus directement il y a au moins
son odeur et
Denisova Denisova 16 vantait pas beau
aussi alors je crois pas que c'est lui
qui est découvert les restes les restes
squelettiques dans la grotte mais en
tout cas c'est c'est son équipe qui a
séquencé
l'ADN de Denisova et qui a démontré que
Denisova était un être humain à part de
Homo sapiens et de l'Homme de Néandertal
cet être humain symptômes dont j'avais
fait une vidéo récemment pour expliquer
un peu où on en était justement et
j'avais d'ailleurs qualifié cette
découverte de
découverte de la décennie voire même du
siècle bon bah vous voyez je n'ai pas
sorti ça nulle part je savais pas à
l'époque que se vantait pas beau à les
recevoir le prix Nobel mais voyez que
c'est c'est dans l'air quoi c'est
c'était là ça on le savait tous si vous
voulez que la découverte de l'homme de
Denisova c'était probablement la
découverte la découverte avec un grand l
quoi
dans ce ventez pas beau félicitations
pour cette pour cette énorme
accomplissement j'ai envie de dire et
pour cette pour la première fois oui il
y a pas d'autre chose à dire c'est la
première fois qu'un paléontologue reçoit
un prix Nobel vous imaginez bien c'est
le prix Nobel de médecine et de
physiologie vous imaginez bien que
depuis le début de l'histoire de la
paléoant anthropologie faut bien se
rendre compte que les premiers paléoant
anthropologues notamment au moins jusque
dans les années 60-70 ils étaient tous
anatomistes et pour être anatomiste il
faut avoir fait des études de médecine
donc ils étaient tous toubib les gars
tous les gars qui ont étudié les
australopithèques les vagins tous ces
premiers toute la première moitié du XXe
siècle ou des gens ont étudié les
hominés ils étaient tous toubibs
quasiment
et il y en a aucun qui a reçu le prix
Nobel de médecine bon bah voilà c'est ça
que vraiment le même le découvreur
d'Australopithecus n'a jamais reçu le
prix Nobel de médecine Yves Coppens n'a
jamais reçu le prix Nobel de médecine
Donald Johansson non plus
faut voir la quantité de gens qui sont
illustres les liquis toute la famille la
dynastie des liquis il y en a aucun qui
a reçu le prix Nobel de médecine donc là
on est sur de la Chipmunk plus plus
c'est de la folie c'est de la folie moi
je suis moi je suis hyper enthousiaste
donc là il faut il faut rendre à ses
arcs qui est à ses arbres bravo à se
vendre t'es pas beau donc qui a
découvert donc il y a quelques
illustrations là c'est le communiqué que
je vous montre là c'est le communiqué
officiel de
de la de du comité du Nobel donc c'est
c'est le matériel que le comité du prix
Nobel a mis en ligne pour annoncer cette
cette nomination
et donc là ça résume un peu la carrière
de se vendre pas beau et notamment c'est
découverte comme je le disais en matière
de d'hybridation imaginez que tout ce
qu'on a pu raconter sur l'hybridation de
Néandertal de Denisova et d'Homo sapiens
tout ça ça vient des tubes à essai de se
vendre pas beau et de son équipe c'est
c'est
ça a juste été complètement partout
tous les ans toutes les deux semaines
vous aviez une nouvelle découverte de
waouh combien combien d'hybridations on
a avec telle et telle espèce et Machin
et tout ça là quand vous avez
certainement entendu dire qu'on a entre
deux et quatre pour cent de génome de
Néandertal nous Européens dans notre ADN
bah c'est se vantait pas beau que voilà
il y a un à 6 % de l'ADN de Denisova
chez les populations d'Asie du Sud-Est
16 vente n'est pas beau et son équipe
donc
c'est grandiose ce qu'il a accompli et
on le félicite encore une fois je ne
cacherai pas mon enthousiasme oui je
radote bravo à lui bravo à son équipe et
on espère que ce sera pas le dernier
vous avez été nombreux article suivant
ah me
faire la remarque que j'avais pas parlé
de ça et anthropus la dernière fois on a
décrit le fameux ou le comme dirait les
Anglais l'un fameux
le fémur de silenthropus entre
guillemets donc le fémur mais il y a
aussi un nul nain apparemment un petit
tulle là donc le matériel post crânien
le squelette les morceaux de squelette
de ça et l'entropus du Tchad et vous
avez été nombreux à me faire remarquer
que j'en avais pas parlé dans le dernier
palais aux news j'en ai pas parlé dans
le dernier Paléo news parce que pour que
ce soit une paléoneuse faut quand même
que ce soit une news et en l'occurrence
ça fait deux ans
ça fait deux ans qu'on nous annonce la
publication prochaine de cet article là
qui était déjà publié en tant que
préprint et j'avais déjà fait une vidéo
PIM je vous la mets je vous avais déjà
fait une vidéo je sais pas de quel côté
elle sera mais bref elle sera de toute
façon dans la description j'avais déjà
fait une vidéo en fait sur cet article
là
qui est l'article on va dire officiel de
l'équipe de Poitiers sur les restes
dominés du Tchad
qu'ils attribuent à Sael anthropus parce
que il y a pas d'autres mini né au Tchad
à cette époque là que ça ait
l'entreprise mais bon dans l'absolu les
comme les fémur elle est Luna comme le
fémur et l'ulnan n'était pas réellement
associé au crâne de Toumaï
c'est c'est une détermination on va dire
faute de mieux appeler ça ça aide
anthropus et c'est une détermination
faute de mieux
mais bon ils ont ils ont quand même ils
ont quand même fait leur boulot j'ai
envie de dire ils ont ils ont regardé
donc bon il y a pas d'extrémité ça se
fait mûr donc c'est assez dur d'en
parler c'est assez dur de raconter une
belle histoire avec mais bon en
regardant l'épaisseur corticale
l'épaisseur corticale c'est donc
l'épaisseur de l'os corticale sur le
fémur ça vous dit quand même la façon
dont l'os était adapté à la distribution
des forces qui étaient appliquées sur
lui donc les forces appliquées sur lui
étant essentiellement le poids du corps
la gravité donc c'est force quand elle
s'applique sur l'os l'os réagit à ses
forces en étant plus épais là où il y a
plus de contraintes et en étant plus fin
là où il y a le moins de contraintes et
donc ces contraintes sont complètement
différentes si vous êtes bipède et si
vous êtes quadrupède donc là d'après la
distribution de l'os cortical de son
épaisseur et des forces qu'on en déduit
de la distribution des forces qu'on en
déduit
on peut dire que ça ils disent en tout
cas que ça et l'entreprise devait être
bipède et même logique avec Lula si vous
êtes si vous vivez au sol comme nous et
que vous vous suspendez jamais avec vos
bras vous allez pas avoir la même
épaisseur d'os corticale et vous allez
pas avoir la même distribution de
l'épaisseur de l'os dans le bras que si
vous vous suspendez régulièrement avec
vos bras donc ça pareil vous regardez
l'épaisseur de l'os corticale comment il
est distribué vous en déduisez si oui ou
non l'animal en question se servait
beaucoup de ses bras pour se suspendre
en l'occurrence oui ça est l'entreprise
visiblement devait se suspendre très
souvent avec ses bras donc il avait
cette dimension fortement
fortement bipède d'un côté et donc ce
qui est le
ce qui confirmerait une bipédie une
bipédie obligatoire étant l'un des
caractères qui unissent à l'entropus
avec les hominés ce n'est pas le seul je
le rappelle il y a aussi des petites
canines la petite taille des canines et
de l'autre côté vous avez donc Luna qui
vous indique quand même il y a toujours
une dimension de bracciation donc
suspend de suspendu aux arbres
qui indique donc que il a toujours cette
héritage signesque j'ai envie de dire
donc ce qui confirme aussi qu'il est
assez proche de la racine des hominés la
racine évolutive j'entends ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que oui et donc comme
je le disais cet article il est sorti il
y a deux ans déjà enfin ça fait deux ans
qu'on sait qu'il existe cet article
alors il va peut-être été remanié un
petit peu mais dans l'ensemble les
conclusions sont les mêmes c'est celle
que je viens de vous dire et elles
étaient les mêmes il y a deux ans donc
cet article est déjà sorti il y a deux
ans et il avait un contrepoint cet
article il y a un autre article de qui a
été produit par une équipe concurrente
je vais pas re-rentrer dans le drama
j'ai découvert tout ça déjà je vais pas
réexpliquer tout ça mais il y a en gros
un autre article d'une équipe
concurrente qui elle a suggéré le
l'inverse voilà que il y avait pas de
dimension bipède dans le fémur
de Side anthropus donc j'en ai déjà
parlé ailleurs et déjà à ce moment là je
disais de toute façon ça change rien à
ce que ça est l'entreprise est même
empruntant du principe que c'est reste
dominé appartiennent à l'entropus ce qui
ne peut pas être démontré à l'heure
actuelle mais même en partant de ce
principe là ça change pas grand chose la
bipédie n'est qu'un seul des facteurs
qui a conduit les gens à attribuer ça et
l'entreprise aux homini et je rappelle
que toutes les phylogénies sérieuses
toutes les analyses phylogénétiques qui
ont été faites avec des vrais
algorithmes mais pas seulement avec
amalvé sur des bouts de papier avec les
opinions de tout un chacun les vrais
phylogénie sérieuses il y en a aucune
qui a contesté cette attribution de sa
et l'entreprise aux homini et aucune
d'entre elles n'a pris en compte le
fémur donc fémur ou pas fémur ça et
l'entreprise pour l'instant et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire c'est à nos mini et
si vous voulez en savoir plus je vous
invite donc à aller voir la vidéo que
j'avais déjà fait sur silenthropus je
vous mets le lien en description
on continue avec les mammifères on
s'éloigne des hominés vous avez
certainement vu passer si vous suivez
les Paléo news
enfin les news l'actualité pas les
anthologique pas les Paléo news les
miennes mais si vous suivez l'actualité
paléontologique vous avez certainement
vu passer cette drôle d'idées
qu'apparemment les mammifères maintenant
ont changé de définition
je sais pas pourquoi ça vient de cet
article là si vous avez vu passer un
truc comme quoi les mammifères étaient
complètement chamboulés et que
maintenant ça on retrouvait des
mammifères jusque dans le Trias
inférieur ou je sais pas quoi je sais
pas je sais pas d'où est sorti c'est
vraiment une
erreur de communication assez assez ouf
je trouve c'était fin août je crois
c'était fin août fin août il y a une
cette espèce de communiquer qui a
circulé
et qui dit ouais qui chamboulait
complètement ce qu'on enfin qui a
annoncé qu'on chamboulait complètement
ce qu'on croyait savoir des mammifères
tout ça c'était attaché à cet article là
que je vous montre maintenant par dessus
dans paru dans le Journal of anatomique
il est un journal tout à fait tout à
fait recevable de publications
scientifique il y a pas de souci et donc
c'est un article qui parle de brasilodon
brasilo donc qui est un sinodon donc
c'est un synodonte non ma malien
c'est-à-dire que et en l'occurrence
brasilodon c'est le dernier sino donc
non Amalia avant
les mammadia forme de mamallia forme
étant ce qu'on peut faire de plus proche
des mammifères sans être un mammifère
donc brasilodon il fait partie un peu de
cette phase transitionnelle entre les
synodontes non Amalia et les et les
mammifères mais brasilodon est en aucun
cas un mammifère et n'en sera jamais un
de ça c'est ça c'est certain donc se
communiquer je sais pas d'où ils ont
sorti cette idée que la définition des
mammifères avait changé les mammifères
ça a été enfin depuis 1986 si je ne
m'abuse
ça ça a été et ce sera pour toujours
désormais
le donc les monotrèmes les marsupiaux
les places inter leur ancêtre en commun
et tous les descendants de cette ancêtre
en commun c'est ça la définition des
mammifères c'est un peu compliqué à
appréhender mais bon c'est juste
l'ancêtre en commun de tous les
mammifères modernes et toutes les
espèces éteintes
qui sont descendantes de cet ancêtre en
commun donc c'est une définition qui est
profondément phylogénétique évidemment
et brasilodon quoi qu'il arrive quel que
soit la situation et toujours exclue de
ça ça c'est la définition du cloud des
mammifères brasilodon il est toujours à
l'extérieur de cette définition quelle
que soit la phylogénie donc il y a
jamais eu d'ambiguïté sur la non
appartenance de brasilodon on mammifères
donc ce que cet article à temps au moins
essaye de démontrer mais je sais d'ores
et déjà que ces conclusions vont être
contestées je sais de sources sûr que
les que ça va pas rester comme ça donc
sachez-le mais en gros ce que cet
article 10 c'est que brasilodon donc le
voilà petit brasilodon on en a retrouvé
plusieurs mandibules 4 en l'occurrence
ils ont fait des sections à l'intérieur
pour regarder le remplacement dentaire
chez brasilodon et ce qu'ils en ont
conclu c'est que brasilodon tout non
mammifère qu'il est avait un
remplacement dentaire d'ifiodontes dit
fiodonte ça veut dire vous avez une
génération de dents de lait une
génération dedans adultes et c'est tout
en tout cas sur les dents post canines
les canines et les incisives elles font
ce qu'elles veulent mais en tout cas sur
les dents post canine c'est à dire les
prémolaires et les molaires brasilodon a
un remplacement dentaire
de mammifères et c'est tout
et c'est pas une grosse surprise puisque
le dans l'arbre phylogénétique vous avez
brasilodon et le suivant c'est Morgan
hugodon et Morgane ucodon il a aussi la
diphyodontie il a aussi un remplacement
dentaire de mammifères et il est très
très proche phylogénétiquement de
brasilodon donc c'est pas si surprenant
que ça de trouver de la diffusion aussi
chez Brazil aux dons donc ça repousse
légèrement l'origine de la diffio Dancie
je suis d'accord ça la repousse au Trias
supérieur pas au Trias inférieur il y a
supérieur
et c'est tout c'est très bien moi ça me
va je veux dire en tant que en tant que
que grand intérêt de des thérapies moi
je suis très content d'apprendre que
brasilodon était dit violente mais il y
a pas de quoi redéfinir le Cloud des
mammifères ni l'origine des mammifères
ça ne réécrit rien du tout
on connaissait pas le remplacement
dentaire de brasilodon et maintenant on
le connaît donc on a remplacé un petit
point d'interrogation par dix fiodoncis
remplacement dentaire de mammifères
félicitations à l'équipe qui a fait ça
comme je vous l'ai dit on attend déjà
une réponse il va y avoir une réponse
d'autres spécialistes je le sais parce
que ce sont des collègues à moi qui le
font il va y avoir une réponse de
spécialiste qui sont pas d'accord avec
ça mais ça ce sera pour le futur c'est
comme ça que ça marche la science
on continue avec les études de
l'ontogénie les études du développement
des juvéniles jusqu'à l'adulte mais
cette fois on passe du côté des
dinosaures avec les très célèbres
cellophéistes de Ghost range les
selophysises de Ghost range vous en avez
forcément entendu parler alors c'est
publié dans scientific reports donc dans
un sous journal de nitcher les
cellofises de Ghost strange que voici
que voilà ce sont les fameux cello
physics j'ai envie de dire qui quand
vous entendez dire par exemple que les
dinosaures étaient cannibales bah 9 fois
sur 10 c'est ce cannibalisme il fait
écho oh c'est l'office de Ghost strange
puisque dans le contenu stomacal de
cesser le physique on a retrouvé des
bébés cellophéisme donc vous le
connaissez forcément vous l'avez vu dans
la dans un des reportages de la BBC à
coup sûr
on s'intéresse beaucoup à leur
développement puisque du coup de fait il
y a des juvéniles et des adultes dans le
même assemblage donc il y a aucun doute
sur le fait qu'ils appartiennent à la
même espèce et aucun doute sur le fait
que c'est la même population j'ai envie
de dire donc on a étudié leur
développement grâce au sections de l'os
ce que vous voyez là ce sont des
sections des faits des sections fines de
l'OS pour regarder la texture de l'os et
on va notamment s'arrêter sur les lignes
d'arrêt de croissance puisque les lignes
d'arrêt de croissance c'est très
intéressant ça nous permet de déterminer
l'âge des dinosaures
et oui il y a des lignes d'arrêt de
croissance chez ces dinosaures ce qui
veut dire qu'ils avaient un une
croissance rythmée par les saisons donc
possiblement pas forcément le sang chaud
en tout cas pas très chaud en tout cas
pas suffisamment chaud pour pour
résister finalement aux variations de
température extérieure quoi qu'il arrive
ces lignes d'arrêt de croissance c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse
c'est pas la question de l'endothermie
qui nous intéresse dans cet article ce
qui nous intéresse c'est sur ces graphes
parce que en fait ce qu'il est
représente sur ce graphe vous avez ici
cette ligne en pointillés c'est la
croissance de l'os donc c'est la
longueur enfin non c'est la
circonférence en l'occurrence de l'os je
peux peut-être vous agrandir tout ça
voilà c'est beaucoup mieux
c'est la circonférence de l'os chez
cédophysisme donc en l'occurrence le
fémur
et dans un monde parfait donc par
exemple chez un crocodile la
circonférence de l'os va s'accroître
avec la l.a.g la distance à la lhg donc
la lhg c'est la last arrested groofline
donc c'est la dernière ligne d'arrêt de
croissance la dernière ligne d'arrêt de
croissance bah c'est là où là ça a
arrêté de grandir quoi donc on regarde
ces lignes d'arrêt de croissance on
mesure la distance de la ligne d'arrêt
de croissance
au centre de Loos et dans un monde
parfait donc cette dernière ligne
d'arrêt de croissance elle va
normalement cette distance va être
complètement parallèle à celle de la
circonférence de l'os c'est ce que vous
voyez ici chez le crocodile c'est ce que
vous voyez ici chez Maya Sora vous voyez
que quand la ligne d'arrêt de croissance
se barre la circonférence de l'os se
barre et là quand ça monte ça monte et
quand ça voilà normalement dans un monde
parfait c'est comme ça que ça se passe
la ligne la dernière ligne d'arrêt de
croissance et la circonférence de l'os
grandissent de concert c'est la
conséquence attendue d'une croissance
saine normale c'est le fusil lui fait
pas ça comme vous pouvez le voir lui ça
a la dernière ligne d'arrêt de
croissance elle joue de l'accordéon dans
l'accordéon alors que l'OS lui continue
de grandir parce que faut quand même
qu'il grandisse le machin tu vois donc
le machin il continue de grandir par
contre ça la distance à la dernière
ligne d'arrêt de croissance elle fait de
l'accordéon et ça ça veut dire que des
fois la croissance va être super rapide
des fois la croissance va être super
lente ça veut dire que c'est le fusil il
était il vivait dans un environnement de
chiottes
des pics de nourriture à certains
moments et des pics de famine à d'autres
du climat qui partait en noisette tous
les 15 jours bref il vivait dans un
environnement pas terrible c'est
l'office et ça se reflète du coup sur sa
morphologie osseuse et là où c'est très
intéressant c'est qu'un article
publié juste avant sur mes amis
sud-africain les masseo spondylus qui
sont des cerises qu'il y a aussi c'est
l'office c'est un théropode mais ma
sauce spondylus lui c'est un seau repos
de morphe et donc les ce repas de mort
c'est pareil on voit leur on voit leur
croissance osseuse ici la ligne en
pointillés tout va bien enfin tout va
bien vous voyez que déjà c'est
c'est pas une belle croissance en ligne
droite comme c'est le fils vous pouvez
plus ou moins résumer ça à une ligne
droite c'est le Masso spondylus c'est
autre chose quand même ma sauce
spondylus il vivait vachement plus près
du pôle aussi l'Afrique du Sud à
l'époque était très près du pôle ma
sauce spondylus il vivait dans un
environnement désertique ou quasi
désertique
c'est ce qu'on voit c'est les dunes
fossilifères enfin les dunes fossilisées
et fossilifères de la formation Clarins
du Golden Gate National Park en Afrique
du Sud c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
à voir aujourd'hui mais alors à l'époque
ils vivent ça devait pas être la fête et
donc ma sauce spondylus il vivait dans
ces dans ces eaux là bon juste en
dessous mais déjà l'environnement était
pas Chouka à l'époque
donc il avait du mal à grandir ça se
voit sur sa ligne de croissance déjà
c'est il y a des il y a des burst de
croissance des arrêts un Birds de
croissance un arrêt un autre burst de
croissance donc ça ça grandit pas à coup
plus que par plus que gentiment
et en plus vous voyez que ça ligne de
ces lignes d'arrêt de croissance c'est
pareil je joue de l'accordéon quoi donc
la distance à la dernière ligne à être
croissance vous voyez là la perturbation
est monumentale quoi donc il y a des
moments où ça où ça pompe de l'os mais
de fou et des moments où ça ça s'arrête
complètement
et ça c'est très intéressant parce que
ça veut dire qu'en gros vous avez deux
clads de dinosaures les cerises enfin
les théropodes et les sans repos de
morphe qui viennent de deux endroits
différents du monde l'un d'une région
qui était quasi tropicale à l'époque
c'est le fils et un autre masse
spondylus d'une région quasi polaire
dans deux climats très différents qui
vous indiquent exactement la même chose
c'était le bordel
et donc donc ce que ça vous dit bah
c'est que effectivement le climat au
début du Jurassic il vivait tous les
deux au début du Jurassique et au début
du Jurassique enfin Trias début
Jurassique et tous les deux ce qui vous
indique c'est que c'était un beau bordel
c'était un bien beau bordel le climat il
était pas tendre avec ses premiers
dinosaures et donc ses premiers
dinosaures avaient appris à s'en sortir
l'un des peut-être l'une l'un des
ingrédients de la recette du succès des
dinosaures là on est au tout début du
règne des dinosaures l'un des
ingrédients pour le succès des
dinosaures c'était peut-être justement
cette flexibilité de croissance et c'est
ça le grand message de cet article et
c'est pour ça qu'il est publié dans une
grande revue la revue ça et en
difficulté parce que justement il nous
indique à pattern commun
à presque tous les dinosaures on n'a pas
encore vu les ornithiciens mais les
ornithiciens du début du Jurassique le
jour où vous les trouvez c'est déjà un
écure en soi mais donc il y a un pattern
chez tous les dinosaures qui semblent
être constante c'est une certaine
flexibilité face au caprice de la nature
et cette flexibilité était peut-être la
recette du succès des dinosaures et
c'est pour ça que cette découverte est
très intéressante
on reste avec les dinosaures on passe à
la revue PLoS oneplus ONE qui est une
revue qui reste généraliste c'est pas
une revue spécialisée en paléontologiste
ça reste une revue généraliste donc
c'est un article qui qui a des
implications par-delà la paléontologie
j'ai envie de dire et c'est le la
fameuse pâte momifi momifiée de
edmontosaurus que vous avez donc vous
avez forcément vu les photos circuler
sur les réseaux sociaux même sans savoir
ce que c'était donc voici une
représentation d'Edmontosaurus voici en
rouge les parties qui sont préservées
et donc c'était de montauzaurus voyez il
a il a de très très belle préservation
ceci est la pâte d'un nez de mentosaurus
regardez la finesse de la préservation
des écailles les détails sont absolument
magnifiques je vais zoomer un peu juste
pour vous montrer là c'est très très
beau c'est très très beau donc on a de
l'os évidemment l'os est préservé à
l'intérieur de la momie mais à
l'intérieur vous voyez ces écailles
cette préservation elle est magnifique
on voit les replis de peau vous voyez
aussi que ça ressemble pas vraiment une
pâte classique de dinosaure ça ça a
quand même une tête un peu un peu chelou
et c'est normal c'est parce que on pense
jamais réellement à se représenter les
tissus mous on pensera très rarement à
se représenter les tissus mous quand on
imagine les dinosaures donc on voit
trois doigts finalement sur le squelette
on s'imagine trois doigts mais non en
fait il y a un doigt là qui est
quasiment complètement fusionné au gros
doigt du milieu et l'autre doit ici qui
est aussi quasiment fusionné au gros
doigt du milieu et ce gros doigt du
milieu lui-même
le résultat de la fusion de deux doigts
vous voyez digitte doigt numéro 4 et
doigt numéro 3 ici donc si vous regardez
une section à travers cette patoune
regardez la beauté de cette patoune
c'est magnifique regardez cette
préservation c'est c'est magique donc on
voit un sabot à la fin d'ailleurs ça
c'est intéressant il y a un sabot au
bout du doigt du milieu et donc en
réalité vous voyez quand on regarde la
section les sections à travers ça qui
sont des sections cityscanes ce sont pas
des vrais ils ont pas réellement découpé
dedans ce sont des sections fait au
rayon X vous voyez 1 2 3 4 doigts en
fait il y a quatre doigts
osseux à l'intérieur de la pâte et le
cinquième qui est là qui fait pas partie
de la section donc c'est quatre doigts
osseux ils sont tous à l'intérieur mais
il y en a deux qui sont fusionnés et
deux qui sont sur le côté là qui sont
tout réduits
donc ça ça vous montre en fait que c'est
pas parce qu'on voit 5 doigts sur le
squelette au final qu'on voit 5 doigts
sur l'animal l'animal en réalité on voit
que 1 2 3 doigts dont deux doigts
réduits mais vous avez des doigts qui
sont fusionnés au milieu donc ça ça vous
apprend quand même un paquet de trucs
mais ceci n'est pas une étude anatomique
c'est une étude tafonomique donc ça nous
parle en fait de comment on est on a
réussi à avoir une préservation comme ça
et cet article est assez intéressant
parce qu'il nous dit qu'en fait il est
il y a plusieurs façons d'obtenir ce
résultat
parce qu'évidemment il y a ça nous
annonce en fait le paradoxe de la
préservation de la momification parce
que pour avoir un résultat comme ça il
faut deux choses il faut une combinaison
de deux facteurs qui arrivent pas
souvent d'abord il faut une momification
il faut que la carcasse soit momifiée
c'est à dire sécher voilà
transformé en viande sèche par le soleil
ou par un autre phénomène par du sel par
exemple si vous vous noyez dans la mer
Morte vous momifié mais par le sel pas
par la pas par le soleil donc d'une il
faut momification des sèchement de la
carcasse sauf que généralement
dessèchement de la carcasse va de paire
avec environnement sec et si vous
connaissez un petit peu vos leçons de
fossilisation vous savez que la
fossilisation il faut de l'eau quelque
part il y a un moment il faut de
l'humidité il faut de l'eau il faut de
la sédimentation il faut qu'un truc
recouvre votre carcasse et ce truc sera
apporté par de l'eau neuf fois sur 10
donc comment est-ce qu'on allie la
momification avec
la fossilisation parce que c'est une
momie fossilisée que vous avez c'est pas
une momie c'est une momie fossilisée
donc comment vous alliez la momification
qui nécessite de la sécheresse avec la
fossilisation qui nécessite de
l'humidité bah ça fait chier
on avait un peu de mal à comprendre et
donc cette momie l'étude de cette momie
nous apporte des réponses donc il y a
comme je vous l'ai dit
l'hypothèse mer morte c'est à dire que
si vous tombez dans un
océan sur Salins dans une mer intérieure
sur saline comme il y a plus d'en avoir
en Amérique du Nord à l'époque il y
avait des petites il y avait une mer
intérieure aux États-Unis au Crétacé et
cette mère intérieure elle avait des
variations et ses variations pouvaient
créer des marques qui étaient sur
salines du coup donc ça c'est une
hypothèse vous avez de l'eau et un
environnement qui va vous dessécher vos
carcasses vous avez les hypothèses donc
après vous avez les dunes l'effondrement
des dunes qui est généralement
l'hypothèse invoquée pour expliquer le
vélociraptor de
le vélociraptor est protocératops qui se
sont fossilisés ensemble en se battant
c'est qu'ils étaient dans un désert ils
se sont battus et il y a une dune qui
s'est effondrée sur leur corps plus ou
moins déjà momifié
l'histoire la légende raconte que ça
c'est que c'est tombé sur eux pendant
qu'il se battaient j'y crois pas trop
moi à mon avis ils se sont d'abord entre
tués leur corps ce sont desséchés mais
en restant coincé dans la position ils
se sont entre tués et ensuite il y a une
dune qui leur qui s'est effondrée sur
leur tronche bon c'est mais en tout cas
voilà c'est une façon d'y arriver il y a
les environnements de type Marne noir
qui vont aussi permettre de conserver
une momie parce que les marnes noires
elles sont anoxiques enfin les marnes
noirs se sont formés dans des dans des
flaques dans des tranches d'eau peu
profondes donc ou invertébrés peut se
retrouver
invertébré non adapté à la vie aquatique
peut se retrouver là dedans donc c'est
une tranche d'eau peu profonde et très
fortement anoxique donc c'est pour ça
qu'elles sont noires c'est parce que la
l'oxydation n'a pas détruit la matière
organique donc c'est très fortement
anoxique et en même temps cette
aquatique donc ça va momifier les
organismes et les fossilisés en même
temps donc tout ça ce sont des
hypothèses qui sont développées dans cet
article et c'est très intéressant de
voir justement comment on essaie de
réconcilier ce qu'ils appellent le
paradoxe des momies fossiles
donc c'est un article très intéressant
il est Open Access et de toute façon
comme d'habitude je vous mets tous les
articles dans la description ceci dit si
vous êtes impressionné par une momie de
pieds de dadrosor qui a allé 70 millions
d'années vous allez être sur le cul en
apprenant qu'on a des momies entières de
liste rosor qui ont 250 millions
d'années c'est cet article que je vous
présente là de Rogers Smith et son
équipe de Captown en Afrique du Sud
l'article est paru en pré-prof alors
pré-prouve c'est pas comme un prêt print
ça a déjà été piridiouvess qui veut dire
que le système de revue par les pairs a
déjà eu lieu donc c'est juste que
l'article est pas encore mis en page
mais il est dans l'état dans lequel il
sera publié un jour mais pas encore
et donc vous allez être sur le cul en
apprenant qu'il y a des momies de
l'hystrosor vous voyez l'isrosort c'est
lui c'est le dissinodonte survivant de
la crise permienrias et regardez ce
cette momie j'en avais déjà parlé de
cette momie c'était pas un secret depuis
2014 elle avait sa découverte avait déjà
été annoncé donc voici la momie de
lysosome le crâne est ici vous voyez les
orbites ici vous voyez là le les
contours du corps les bras les jambes là
vous voyez les contours du corps et donc
les contours du corps sont marqués par
de la peau qui a été préservée regardez
et on voit la peau veruqueuse ce qui me
suivent sur les réseaux sociaux sur les
réseaux sociaux ont vu que en août quand
on était sur le terrain on a découvert
une magnifique petite patoune de
lysosome momifié et envoyé très très
bien cet aspect verruqueux de la peau
sur ce sur ce disposeur sur cette
patoune de listrosor voilà suivez-nous
sur les réseaux sociaux Instagram
Twitter hashtag en tractions un tractus
suivez-nous sur les réseaux sociaux je
publie des photos de fossiles et
notamment quand je suis sur le terrain
les fossiles qu'on découvre et donc
on a découvert des magnifiques petites
mains de lysosor fossilisés avec la peau
encore préservée et c'est exactement ça
qu'on voit cette peau à texture
verrueuse magnifique chez listosaurus
donc ça c'est une momie enfin c'est une
momie fossilisée d'un animal qui vivait
il y a 250 millions d'années au début du
Trias donc comparé à la drozor qui avait
à peu près 70 millions d'années on est
180 millions d'années plus vieux
180 millions d'années c'est quasiment
200 millions d'années c'est c'est
c'est titanesque cette titanes c'est
c'est trois fois la distance qui nous
sépare du dernier tyrannosaure c'est
enfin c'est trois fois le temps pas la
distance du coup c'est trois fois le
temps qui nous sépare d'un tyrannosaure
c'est c'est ouf c'est oufissime cette
préservation et donc on a ce genre de
préservation dans le début du Trias dans
le carreau en Afrique du Sud et rien que
ça c'est prodigieux je crois qu'il y a
d'autres photos de cette momie dans le
corps de texte juste qu'il faut que
j'arrive à tomber dessus et c'est pas
forcément évident vous voyez il y a de
l'histologie qui a été fait sur ces sur
ces momies il y a pas que l'hystrosaurus
qui a été décrit à la voilà
donc là on en remontre la peau versuse
et on a une meilleure vue de cette de
cette momie ici bon il est pas encore
publié donc comme j'ai dit c'est pas
encore mis en page il y a cette espèce
de watermark là qui traîne au milieu
c'est pas hyper agréable à lire dans
l'état mais bon un jour peut-être et on
nous parle aussi de cette et on nous
parle aussi de ce petit patch vous voyez
d'ossements mon petit patch qui fait
quand même plus de 2 mètres de long dans
cette cette
occurrence de fossiles cette assemblage
ce bonne bed qui contient 13 lysosaurus
juvénile ensemble comme ça
assembler tous ensemble complètement
mélangé les uns avec les autres les
zones ne sont pas tellement en
articulation ils sont complètement
mélangés les uns avec les autres c'est
un des c'est un des arguments du coup
pour dire qu'ils étaient au moins un
petit peu grégaire en période de
sécheresse l'hypothèse étant qui se sont
probablement retrouvés autour d'une mare
au dernier moment de leur vie à essayer
de survivre on va dire avec le peu d'eau
qui restait et de peu de nourriture qui
restait autour de cette marque donc ils
avaient au moins un comportement
grégaire
plus ou moins grégaire en période de
sécheresse mais c'est donc c'est un
article qui nous explique en fait que la
tafonomie de l'estrosaurus la façon dont
l'hystrosaurus est préservée dans le
registre fossile et si vous connaissez
pas la tafonomie je vous invite à aller
voir les vidéos de mon très cher ami
Raphaël lannon 3 une série de trois
vidéos trois cours sur la tafonomie
justement donc la tafonomie de nos
listrosaurus nous indique que on était
dans un environnement très très perturbé
très très sec donc qui a permis
justement la momification de nos
listrotsaurus alors c'est momie ce sont
des momies d'environnement sèches secs
en l'occurrence
qui ont ensuite été recouverts par des
événements de ce qu'on appelle en
anglais des flash flots donc des
des inondations soudaines qui sont venus
les recouvrir immédiatement d'un
sédiment un peu grossier et c'est pour
ça aussi que la préservation n'est pas
aussi belle que celle de notre atrosant
momifié notre explication pour ça c'est
que comme je l'ai dit elles sont 180
millions d'années plus vieilles mais des
momies quand même à 104 à 250 millions
d'années c'est pas rien on est
immédiatement d'ailleurs après la grande
crise permis à Trias dans ce site du
début du Trias qui s'appelle fairy Dale
on est immédiatement après le la crise
permienrias donc on est encore une fois
dans un environnement extrêmement
perturbé la crise perméatrias c'est
celle juste avant la crise
Trias Jurassic dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure et sans transition nous
allons terminer avec des poissons les
petits poissons
les petits poissons du Silurien des
petits poissons du Silurien alors
d'abord je vais vous afficher ceci voilà
donc les petits poissons si le rien de
Chine qui ont défrayé la chronique
puisque si on en croit le communiqué de
presse il réécrivent totalement encore
une fois l'histoire de l'évolution de
l'origine des vertébrés les communiqués
de presse évidemment ils sont là pour
vous vendre du rêve que nous disent
réellement ces articles et bien voilà ce
qui nous disent réellement on a donc
deux nouveaux sites en Chine
dont l'existence nous a vient de nous
être révélés dans la revue nation donc
c'est les quatre articles dont je vais
vous parler juste après et ces deux
nouveaux sites qui sont datés d'environ
430 millions d'années donc du début du
Silurien
on fournit des fossiles qui viennent
remplir on va dire un vide dans le
registre fossile assez conséquent c'est
le c'est le début en fait de la grande
radiation des des poissons
donc le dévonia est en connu comme l'âge
des poissons a été précédé par ainsi le
rien qui aurait dû être un âge du début
des poissons
mais on n'avait pas tellement de faux
cils on avait des restes
fragmentaire par-ci par là on avait
notamment des écailles
des écailles avec de l'émail dessus de
l'enaméloïde qui aurait pu appartenir à
ce qu'on appelle des acanthodiens des
poissons des poissons à mâchoire qui
ressemblent fortement à des poissons
cartilagineux mais sont en réalité
osseux mais ces écailles auraient pu
tout aussi bien appartenir à des
condriens donc des poissons
cartilagineux les ancêtres de nos
requins de nos raies et de nos chimères
actuels
donc on avait ces écailles qui aurait pu
appartenir aussi bien aux incantés
là très parcellaire on n'était pas on
savait qu'ils étaient là si vous voulez
ces poissons on avait des preuves qu'ils
étaient là mais pas vraiment de beaux
fossiles et donc ce que nous apporte ces
articles au moins en partie ce sont pour
la première fois des beaux fossiles daté
de cette époque alors il y a du bon et
il y a du mauvais dans ces articles tous
ces articles ont été publiés par la même
équipe donc l'équipe d'un chercheur
chinois qui s'appelle minzu alors je
sais pas du tout comment ça se prononce
mais ce son nom revient sur chacun des
quatre articles dont on va parler
maintenant et donc comme je le disais il
y a du bon et il y a du mauvais et à mon
avis il aurait pas été de mauvais temps
que les éditeurs de nightcher
disent ah c'est à mingzu et à son équipe
de on va dire de condenser tout ça en un
seul article ou en deux parce qu'il y a
des grosses répétitions là par exemple
on a un article qui est titré le premier
miniatostome enfin les dents du premier
natostome et juste après on a un autre
article qui s'appelle le plus ancien
Joe verte donc vertébrés à mâchoire à
donc on a des grosses répétitions dans
les dans les dans les dans les
découvertes qui sont annoncées en fait
c'est à dire que c'est quasiment le même
titre on nous annonce le premier
gnatostome le premier gnatostome sauf
que là c'est le premier gnatostome
complet et là c'est la première dans
isolée enfin les premières dents isolées
de gnatostome est-ce que ça aurait pas
valu le coup éventuellement de mettre
tout ça ensemble pour dire on a les
premiers knatostome voici leurs dents
voici leur squelette
[Musique]
auditorial au niveau de nightcher et la
raison pour laquelle je m'arrête là
dessus c'est parce que je dois le
rappeler nitcher c'est l'une des plus
grandes revues scientifiques
d'aujourd'hui avec la revue Science donc
nature c'est pas Joe le rigolo
normalement et comme je l'avais déjà
expliqué dans une vidéo précédente
pourquoi est-ce que c'est prestigieux de
publier dans nightcher bah parce que
quand on publie dans nightcher on publie
si vous voulez quand on quand on va
publier dans nightcher on paye voilà on
paye pour publier dans nightcher c'est
pas eux qui nous payent pour publier je
rappelle le système du fonctionnement du
pér review parce que enfin du système de
publication des revues à comité de
lecture parce que c'est ça semble
bizarre à beaucoup de monde donc on paye
pour c'est nous qui payons pour publier
nos articles c'est pas le même système
que pour les bouquins où tu te fais
payer pour une œuvre que littéraire que
quelqu'un d'autre va publier c'est toi
qui paye pour que ton œuvre soit publier
et la raison pour ça normalement c'est
que ce que tu payes c'est le prestige de
la revue ce que tu achètes ce que tu
loues avec cette argent que tu payes
c'est le prestige de la revue donc que
tu sois chinois en l'occurrence là pour
ces gens-là que tu sois un jeune
chercheur parce que l'exemple que
j'avais expliqué dans ma vidéo
précédente où j'avais parlé justement de
de baronne qui était un étudiant je sais
plus s'il était en master ou en pillage
dit mais il était encore étudiant baron
qui avait publié cette grande phylogénie
des dinosaures où il introduisait le
concept d'ornithos elida donc concurrent
des ceriskias dans la classification des
dinosaures
cette ça avait été publié dans nightcher
et donc ce que cette étudiant s'était
acheté avec nature c'était la
possibilité justement de diffuser
ce concept d'ornithos et Lida
dans une grande revue à comité de
lecture pour que tout le monde puisse
justement avoir un avis là-dessus voilà
ça au lieu de publier ça dans une revue
moins chère voire gratuite mais beaucoup
plus cryptique on a ce jeune étudiant
qui s'est permis justement de pouvoir
diffuser ça au plus grand nombre grâce à
la renommée de la revue nation donc ce
qu'on achète ce qu'on paye c'est la
renommée de la revue c'est la
possibilité aussi d'avoir des retours
des retours critiques la science c'est
le c'est
la dictature j'ai envie de dire du pire
review c'est la dictature de la revue
par les pairs et cette dictature assure
le bon fonctionnement justement de la
science
si vous publiez vos résultats dans une
revue et que personne les voit que ce
sont des résultats
controversés mais que personne les voit
bah il n'y aura pas de controverse il
n'y aura pas de pire review
et donc vos résultats ne vaudront rien
en réalité puisque personne les aura vu
donc c'est pour ça qu'on paye pour
publier dans la revue nation et c'est
pour ça que je suis très critique là
pour le coup de de la ligne éditoriale
de nitcher qui
étale au final des découvertes sur
plusieurs articles enfin qui acceptent
d'étaler des découvertes sur plusieurs
articles alors même que
tous ces articles à mon avis auraient
beaucoup mieux mérité soit d'être
fusionné tous ensemble soit d'être
publié ailleurs pour pouvoir expliquer
pourquoi c'était plus important on va
notamment voir ça avec cet article là
cet article ce qui nous annonce la
découverte d'un nouveau acanthodien cet
article là à mon avis il aurait mérité
d'être publié dans une autre revue moins
prestigieuse mais qui aurait pas un
nombre de caractères limités parce que
nightcher il y a ça aussi il y a le
nombre de caractères limités donc vous
êtes obligé de faire des articles courts
quand vous faites des articles dans
nitcher ils seront obligés généralement
ces trois quatre pages pas plus
et vous avez pas le temps d'expliquer
des grandes choses en trois quatre pages
c'est pas possible alors il y a les
supplémentaries matériels mais soyons
tout à fait honnêtes très très peu de
gens lisent les supplémentaires
immatériales donc les appendices si vous
préférez en français il y a peu de gens
qui lisent ça et encore une fois je dis
ça aurait mérité d'être publié dans une
revue moins prestigieuse je dis pas ça
devrait ça devrait être jeté à la
poubelle dans une revue moi prestigieuse
non ça mérite d'être publié dans une
revue moins prestigieuse mais qui permet
de s'étaler en longueur sur des cons sur
des explications qui ici ne sont pas
fournies et qui manquent donc c'est pour
ça c'est pas c'est pas de la haine que
je mais je me permets d'être un peu
critique sur ce qui a motivé nature
finalement à accepter ces articles ces
articles pour certains auraient dû être
fusionnés et pour d'autres aurait dû
être publiés dans des revues qui
permettaient justement de fournir plus
d'explications donc sans plus de
bavardages parce que ça fait déjà un
moment que je bavarde là
sans plus bavardage donc parlons de ces
articles alors on nous annonce donc il y
a deux il y a comme je l'ai dit il y a
deux nouveaux sites du Silurien certains
qui ont fourni donc ces dents isolées et
un accord toddien dont on va parler et
un autre site qui a fourni un
ostéostracer c'est à dire un truc qui
ressemble assez fasses comme vous pouvez
le voir si vous connaissez ces falaspi
vous avez certainement vu le reportage
BBC où on voit ses falaspi sur la terre
des monstres disparus si je ne m'abuse
et puis on a ces deux trucs alors ça
c'est les plus intéressants on va en
parler on va en parler il y a ces deux
trucs
qui ressemble à des placodermes mais qui
ressemble aussi à des condriques tiens
donc on va voir on va en parler et tout
ça ça vient de deux nouveaux sites du
Silurien inférieur de Chine alors vous
voyez autour de 425 millions d'années
430 millions d'années à peu près
donc on commence par les plus vieilles
dents de guinatostumes les gnatostome
étant les vertébrés à mâchoire les
poissons à mâchoire aussi comme on les
appelle parfois ces poissons à mâchoire
ils sont donc les descendants d'un
groupe de poissons sans mâchoire dont on
va parler tout à l'heure qui s'appelle
les ostéostracées donc c'est pas
laspistes par exemple fait partie des
Ostéostracés c'est un poisson qui n'a
pas de mâchoire et ses poissons sans
mâchoire sont les ancêtres des poissons
à mâchoire et ils avaient cette
particularité d'avoir une énorme
carapace sur la tête donc on parle de on
parle de de poissons cuirassés donc et
là ce qu'on a c'est des dents alors et
c'est même pas des dents d'ailleurs ce
sont des rouleaux dentaires alors je
m'excuse de la qualité de cet article
c'est une photocopie je n'ai pas réussi
à le trouver en original mais du coup je
suis allé glaner des photos sur internet
donc là vous voyez vous avez cette
figure là par exemple je suis allé la
reglaner sur internet en haute qualité
et en couleur pour pouvoir vous montrer
à quoi ressemble ces rouleaux alors ces
rouleaux vous voyez ce sont des des
rouleaux avec des
qui pousse de l'arrière non pas dans qui
pousse vous avez labial ici la lingual
ici donc lingual c'est du côté de la
langue labiale c'est du côté des lèvres
donc oui les dents elles poussent de ce
côté-ci et elle enfin elle naissent de
ce côté-ci et elle pousse de ce côté-là
et ensuite elles sont elles sont
résorbées de ce côté là et ça ça fait
penser à un remplacement dentaire de
requins
ce qu'on rencontre chez les chondriciens
de manière générale sauf les chimères
donc ça fait penser à un remplacement
dentaire de requins à part que c'est
juste un rouleau en fait les dents elles
sont comme ça elles sont en un rouleau
et c'est des rouleaux isolés ce qui est
un truc qu'on semble retrouver assez
souvent chez les poissons du Dévonien
notamment
donc on sait pas vraiment à quoi il
ressemblait cette reconstitution ici
c'est du pifomètre plus plus on va pas
se le cacher mais on sait pas à quoi
vraiment il ressemblait mais bon bah ça
a une structure dedans et ça a un type
de remplacement de dentaire proche de ce
des condictiens donc ils font
l'hypothèse raisonnable selon moi que ça
devait appartenir à quelque chose
d'assez proche des condriens je ne
conteste pas ça mais comme je l'ai dit
c'est relativement redondant avec les
articles suivants
qui décrivent des accords toadiens et
des placoderm là et l'autre étant aussi
des poissons à mâchoire donc des
gnatostome et qui date de la même époque
donc au final c'est une découverte qui
est assez redondante avec les
découvertes suivantes notez qu'ils en
font quand même une nouvelle espèce
ça va être important pour la suite donc
il s'appelle ça Kia nodus duplicis donc
ils en font une nouvelle espèce de ce
qui anodus du Plessis et dans le même
site donc ils ont découvert le premier à
quant audien et alors déjà le titre il
m'a pas plu le premier conducteur un
conduit tiens épineux c'est parce que ça
fait écho au fait que les
incontournières on les appelait
autrefois les requins les requins
épineux parce que ça ressemble à des
cons ça ressemble à des chondridiens
primitifs les chondriciens primitifs
ressemblant eux-mêmes à des requins et
donc c'est et ils ont des épines donc
les aquatodias ils sont connus pour ça
c'est ce que akantodia veut dire
d'ailleurs un cantonien veut dire plein
d'épines et là je commence à avoir un
petit problème avec cet article là parce
que ce qu'ils ont trouvé donc c'est des
milliers de restes isolés c'est ce qu'il
décrivent ici
Morgan spécimens
plus de 1000 spécimens isolés et je ne
sais par quelle magie ils ont décidé que
tout ça appartenait à un seul et même
animal
et ça et là je suis pas expert en
poissons du Silurien ni du Dévonien mais
à mon avis enfin je suis pas sûr que la
pratique soit tout à fait légit
je sais pas je sais pas s'il y a un
expert là qui m'écoute en poissons du
dévonia est-ce que c'est normal de
prendre des morceaux comme ça à droite
et à gauche et de tous les rassembler
pour dire hey ils appartiennent tous au
même gars donc alors il décrivent un
petit peu après que il y a
éventuellement des morceaux qui se
recouvrent parce que c'est pas
évidemment c'est plein de morceaux qui
ont attribué à la même espèce mais on
est bien d'accord que ça n'appartient
pas du tout au même individu ça même eux
sont pas dupe de ce de ce fait là ils
ont des donc du coup ils ont des
chevauchements du fait que ça appartient
pas tous au même individu ils ont des
chevauchements de morceaux enfin vous
voyez que les morceaux qui se recouvrent
ils sont où je veux dire à part au
niveau de la ceinture scapulaire où vous
avez des morceaux qui sont en connexion
justement le type est un fragment de
ceinture scapulaire d'ailleurs
donc le spécimen de référence est à une
ceinture scapulaire et donc vous avez
cette ceinture scapulaire qui est à peu
près la seule chose où vous pouvez avoir
des morceaux qui se chevauchent mais là
les épines il y en a aucune qui est peut
se recouvrir avec les pinne de derrière
ou devant c'est bizarre moi je trouve ça
hyper chelou qu'on leur est permis de
publier ça dans nightcher là pour le
coup c'est c'est là que ça devient un
problème c'est que moi j'aurais voulu
une explication en long en large et en
travers de pourquoi ils ont assemblé
tous ces morceaux ensemble et dans
Nature tu peux pas faire ça tu peux pas
expliquer pourquoi vous avez pourquoi tu
as assemblé tous ces morceaux et j'ai
regardé c'est pas non plus expliquer
dans les appendices ou alors ou alors je
l'ai raté et dans ce cas là peut s'il
vous plaît montrez-moi
mais mais ouais je suis pas convaincu du
coup par l'assemblage de tout ça et
alors ils font une analyse
phylogénétique donc ils assemble tout ça
ils en font une nouvelle espèce
fanging
Fang Chania ici Franck jeania rénovata
ils en font donc une nouvelle espèce et
un nouveau genre
et il met ça dans une analyse
philogénétique et comme ils ont utilisé
climatisus donc un autre acanthodien
mieux connu puisque lui on l'a retrouvé
tout articulé donc comme ils ont utilisé
climatus comme modèle pour réassembler
leur mille pièces isolées tous ensemble
bah curieusement Franck ging chia
fanging Chania pardon se retrouve
branché dans un Cloud avec climatillus
pas exactement une énorme surprise et
donc les acanthodiens finissent comme
stem-group donc groupe racine des
chondria le plus ancien condrien étant
deux lieux du doliodus qui associe le
remplacement dentaire en rouleau des
requins qu'on retrouve chez les requins
et les raies modernes avec la présence
d'épines sur les sur les côtés des
acanthodiens justement qu'on retrouve
chez les acanthodiens
donc dans le lieu du Sila cette
association et il a un squelette
cartilagineux donc doliodus a le
squelette cartilagineux des condrien
alors que les accords todia avaient
encore à squelette osseux on pensait à
une époque que le squelette
cartilagineux était plus primitif que le
squelette osseux c'est pas le cas comme
je vous l'ai dit tous les tous les
poissons sans mâchoire qui précédaient
ces poissons à mâchoire là ils avaient
tous à squelette osseux massif ils
avaient tous cette carapace cette
cuirasse et tous ces gens là tous ces
toutes ces bestioles là là elles étaient
précédées aussi par les placoderm qu'on
voit normalement un petit peu plus haut
là sur la figure là c'est les ostéiciens
voilà les Placoderme donc tout ce beau
monde là ça a été précédé
phylogénétiquement par les placoderm les
placodermes qui ont eux aussi une
carapace donc le los a précédé le
cartilage dans cette histoire
et donc la perte de l'os est une
synapomorphy de fait est un caractère
dérivé propre aux chondricien deux lieux
deus avait
ce squelette cartilagineux il a le
remplacement dentaire des chondriciens
ce qui en fait un convecteur mais il a
aussi des épines
d'acantodia donc naturellement les
accords tiens de se mettre proche des
chondriciens dans cette phylogénie je
pareil j'en fais le détail je fais le
détail de tout ça parce que c'est
important et donc de fait que fanging
Shania vient du Silurien inférieur en
fait ça pousse l'arbre phylogénétique
naturellement beaucoup plus profondément
dans leur devicien donc maintenant en
fait on s'attend même à trouver de
des
on s'attend même à trouver de fait des
accrochodiens dans jusque dans leur
deviciens ceci étant dit encore une fois
fangine Chania est une chimère ils ont
ils ont assemblé des trucs de plusieurs
individus et voire même de plusieurs
essais parce que justement dans
l'article précédent ici il décrivent une
nouvelle espèce donc il y a un nombre n
supérieur à une espèce de poisson et il
le mentionne ici les il y a des il y a
des rouleaux dentaires qui appartiennent
pas qui n'appartiennent pas à
fonctionnia dans cette dans cet
assemblage il le disent dans le texte
donc il y a d'autres espèces de poissons
que fanching Shania dans cette
assemblage donc en vertu de quoi
assemblez-vous tous ces restes pour en
faire une seule et même nouvelle espèce
je
suis perplexe je suis très perplexe
quant aux résultats de franchine Chania
et comme j'ai dit ça aurait mérité tout
ça aurait mérité d'être beaucoup plus
détaillé dans un article qui dans une
revue qui aurait permis justement un
texte suffisamment long pour pouvoir
expliquer tout ça donc ça ça fonctionne
Shania
ça ça aurait demandé un peu plus de
détails et je suis assez sceptique de
ces résultats sur ce sur cette
acanthodien
on passe maintenant au Placoderme donc
ils ont aussi la même équipe toujours
minzu vous voyez toujours là
on passe maintenant au Placoderme
toujours publié dans nightcher toujours
dans le même volume donc ces placoderm
hop les voilà magnifique vous voyez là
là pour le coup les fossiles je vais pas
je vais pas pinailler là on voit ce que
c'est des fossiles ils sont tout
articulés ils sont magnifiques donc là
contrairement à la quantodia je vais pas
exprimer de gros doutes quant à quant à
l'attribution de ces choses là a des
placoderm vous voyez que les fossiles
sont sont de bonne facture on a même des
on a même des photos supplémentaires
dans les dans les appendices ici vous
voyez il y a d'autres photos de ces
placoderm on voit très bien les fossiles
on voit très bien la différence entre
l'os et le sédiment il y a pas de doute
sur l'interprétation on a même un scan
qui a été fait qui permet d'isoler un
peu mieux le truc et donc ce qui est
intéressant avec ces placoderm c'est
qu'ils ont effectivement la carapace
d'un Placoderme donc il y a pas de doute
là-dessus ils ont la carapace céphalique
et nuccale d'un Placoderme donc ils ont
une contrairement justement aux
ostéostracées sans mâchoire ils ont une
carapace sur la tête et ils ont une
carapace sur le coup donc ça c'est très
typique des Placoderme aucun doute
là-dessus je j'accepte totalement et en
plus ce qu'il y a c'est qu'il y a des
épines sur le côté regardez elles sont
très très nettes très très bien
préservées donc là vous avez vu dorsale
vue ventrale et regardez là au dessus de
la nageoire ou de là où aurait dû se
localiser la nageoire vous avez des
épines des épines exactement comme chez
les accantes audiiens et les premiers
requins tels que doliodius et ça c'est
hyper intéressant parce que normalement
il y a pas d'épines au dessus des
nageoires pectorales chez les
placodermes ils ont pas ça normalement
les placoderm donc non seulement vous
avez un Placoderme du Silurien ce qui en
fait le plus ancien l'un des plus
anciens du moins Placoderme au monde
c'est ce qu'on voit ici sur la sur la
phylogénie donc celui avec la grosse
carapace là et les épines sur le côté
c'est jonchianosteus et donc ils en
décrivent un autre qui s'appelle China
Cantus et vous voyez donc sur la
philogénie que chez lacus et junction
ostéus ce sont les plus vieux
Placoderme connu il y a pas les autres
placoderm vous voyez les barres sont
dans le dévonia là tous les Placoderme
sont là ici vous avez des accantes
audias donc les avec un cantonais ici
par exemple qui est très très qui est
beaucoup plus jeune comparé aux autres
mais vous avez les autres accords
todiens qui sont ici entre la fin du
Silurien et le début du Dévonien
et donc Shug chanostéus lui il se fout
avec les autres placoderm donc il
ressemble comme je le disais vous voyez
il a une bonne tête de Placoderme avec
les épines en plus qui est très
intéressant et donc sunshouse ici pareil
physique de Placoderme avec une épine
sur le dos comme un incantéen ou un
ou un convectien et ça du coup dans leur
phylogénie ça se reflète ici avec le
fait que chez natanthus vient se mettre
bien former un groupe avec les accords
toddiens les accords todias qui sont
paraphilétiques à la base des
chondriciens donc il se retrouve assez
proche finalement des cambrides en plus
on a on a ce côté un peu bizarre ou en
fait la même équipe publie de phylogénie
différentes avec
justement des des espèces enfin une un
échantillonnage taxonomique différent
dans l'une et dans l'autre
encore une fois est-ce que ça aurait pas
valu le coup de fusionner ces deux
analyses phylogénétiques pour en faire
une grande analyse philogénétique
synthétique parce que là vous voyez que
climatius là il se retrouve tout seul
ici alors que la climatisus il est
accompagné de frangines Shania et de
parexus
alors que là il y a même pas pareils
donc pourquoi avoir fait deux analyses
phylogénétiques complètement différentes
avec deux assemblages taxonomiques avec
deux
échantillonnages taxonomiques
complètement différents alors que vous
auriez pu faire un article avec une
grande analyse
philogénétique qui aurait réconcilié
tout le monde parce que de fait par
définition c'est deux analyses de fait
ce contredisent alors que c'est la même
équipe qui alors que c'est la même
équipe qu'il l'a fait donc dans ce
résultat de cette analyse c'est oh
regardez franchine Chania c'est un
nouveau chaînon manquant je mets des
petites guillemets c'est un nouveau
chaînon manquant entre les accords
todias et les et les chondriciens et là
vous avez chez lacanthus c'est un
nouveau chez nos manquant entre les
accords todias et les chondriciens
alors qu'elles sont faites par les mêmes
personnes publiées dans la même revue et
en même temps
à mon avis ça aurait valu le coup de
fusionner ces articles mais bon c'est là
pour le coup je ne conteste pas
l'importance de ces résultats ce sont
des résultats extrêmement importants
ce sont des fossiles très très
importants qui comme je dis là on a on a
vraiment un assemblage de caractères qui
fait de chez lacanthus un intermédiaire
entre les placoderm là si vous regardez
que la tête c'est un Placoderme si vous
regardez que là vous avez une épine de
vous avez une épine d'un cantonien et
pareil pour l'autre pour l'autre là haut
vous avez si vous regardez au milieu
c'est un Placoderme si vous regardez sur
le côté vous avez une épine
d'acanthodien il y a toujours eu cette
espèce de dualité en fait entre les
accords toadiens et les placodermes il y
a des gens qui disent que les placoderm
d'un côté ce sont les ancêtres des
chondriciens il y a ceux qui de l'autre
côté disent que les
placodermiens sur les ancêtres des
chondriciens et le problème c'est que
les deux hypothèses ont des énormes
lacunes les acanthodiens ce sont des
poissons
osseux qui ont un opercule
donc il ressemble pas du tout à des
conducteurs et de l'autre côté on a les
placoderm qui
certes ont qui qui ont des Terry copodes
comme les chondriciens et dont certains
ne pondez pas d’œufs comme certains
chondricients modernes
c'est notamment le cas de materpicis
athenboro qui dont on a retrouvé des
fœtus à l'intérieur donc des pas dans
des œufs du coup des foetus dans la dans
la cavité abdominale et c'est pas du et
c'est pas de la c'est pas de la du
cannibalisme donc on a des preuves d'un
côté comme en fait on a d'un côté les
accords toadiens ouais qui ressemblent
superficiellement à des condriques tiens
qui ont notamment les mêmes écailles de
type placoïdes sur le corps mais qui
mais qui ont une anatomie interne de
poissons osseux pas de poisson
cartilagineux et on a de côté
ces placoderm qui partagent pas mal de
traits en commun avec les boissons
cartilagineux avec le le gros crâne le
gros crâne osseux en moins évidemment
mais qui ont quand même ces c'est très
de la notamment de la biologie
reproductive avec les petits rigobodes
et avec dans ce qu'on appelle les
classes peur en anglais et la biologie
reproductive en général qu'il partage ça
avec les chondriciens c'est un bordel
les poissons cuirassés
c'est un bordel les poissons cuirassés
et donc vous avez cette espèce de ces
deux théories en fait qui font naître
les chondriciens parmi les poissons
cuirassés et les autres qui les font
naître parmi les accords toddiens donc
eux ils ont quand même l'air d'être
plutôt pour la l'hypothèse acanthodienne
mais du coup avec cet article là on
aurait peut-être une réconciliation en
fait des deux hypothèses
puisque là on aurait un truc qui aurait
à la fois donc chez natanthus qui aurait
à la fois des traits de placoderm et des
traits à kantodia donc qui qui
mélangerait le meilleur des deux j'ai
envie de dire et qui réconcilierait de
fait la les deux hypothèses Placoderme
origine placoder mais origine
acanthodienne
faisant par la même des placodermes
comme des accords todies des groupes
complètement pétés ce qu'on appelle
paraphilétique au mieux par affilettique
voire polyphilétique et on termine ce
paléone news avec cet article l'article
donc toujours de l'équipe de Mizu
toujours dans nightcher et qui cette
fois décrit non pas un poisson à
mâchoire tous les trois articles que je
vous ai dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure était à propos de poissons à
mâchoire mais celui-là est à propos d'un
poisson sans mâchoire un acniate comme
on les appelle de la famille des galets
aspidés elle est galée à speeder ils
font partie de ce grand groupe des
Ostéostracés dont ces falaspices fait
partie aussi les ostéostracées ce sont
les boissons sans mâchoire qui
ressemblent à des aspirateurs
on va on va rester simple on va rester
simple parce que c'est déjà compliqué là
entre galets à speed agnate ostéostracée
on a déjà suffisamment listé de jargon
c'est pas la peine d'en rajouter donc
dans la grande famille des ostréostracés
je demande les aspirateurs donc les
aspirateurs les voici les voilà donc ça
ressemble un peu comme je le disais à
cephalaspi ça le vous avez ce gros
bouclier
céphalique ce gros bouclier qui forme le
crâne avec les yeux ici vous avez les
ailes sur les côtés du bouclier
céphalique et alors chez ces falaspi
normalement ici on a des nageoires et
avoir donc des nageoires pectorales et
chez ces falaspi c'est nageoire pectoral
c'est la première fois qu'on les voit en
fait les normalement les poissons
agnates n'ont pas de nageoires si vous
pensez à la lampe roi par exemple ils
ont pas de nageoires pectoral si vous
pensez aux terrasses pido morphe donc la
terrassic étant l'un des plus des plus
célèbres si vous pensez à un aspis
si vous pensez à tous ces poissons à
mâchoire des poissons sans mâchoire du
Dévonien la plupart d'entre eux n'ont
pas de nageoires pectorale il y a que
les ostéostracées qui ont des nageoires
pectorales c'est falaspis à des
nageoires pectorales et c'est nageoires
pectoral bah c'est ce qui va un jour
devenir vos bras voilà donc quelques
millions d'années plus tard on est bien
d'accord mais ça va devenir les bras
donc c'est une innovation c'est une
synapomorphy que les ostéostracées
partagent avec les poissons à mâchoire
donc quand on parle de l'évolution des
ostéostracées on parle aussi de
l'origine des poissons à mâchoire c'est
eux qui un jour vont avoir une mâchoire
et donc là le simple fait d'avoir
ce galet à speeder dans les mêmes
gisements que nos placodermes nos
aquanthodiens et notre truc avec des
rouleaux dentaires là ça vous montre que
déjà la divergence elle a eu lieu
donc on est aussi Luria on est au début
du Silurien et on a déjà de tout donc
déjà rien que ça c'est intéressant donc
ça c'est intéressant ça montre que la
divergence entre
ostéostrasse et poisson à mâchoire elle
a eu lieu bien avant ça probablement à
l'heure de vicié voire même au cambriant
c'est déjà ce qui était suggéré c'est
déjà ce qui était suggéré en fait dans
les phylogéniques vous voyez là si ils
ont voyez les galets à speeder sont ici
les ostéostracées sont là donc
d'ailleurs les galets aspider je vois
erreur de ma part ne sont pas considérés
comme des ostéostracées mais comme le
groupe frère des Ostéostracés autant
pour moi enfin le groupe frère des
Ostéostracés et des
et des vertébrés à mâchoire donc autant
pour moi les galets à speeder bah du
coup manque de comme vous voyez ici là
le ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
tissu mou ici vous indique le tissu mou
est préservé et les nageoires ne sont
pas là donc en fait ça les exclut les
ostéostracées autant pour moi
donc les gars les aspider sont groupes
frères des ostéostracées il leur manque
les nageoires pour être des
ostéostracées
et comme vous le voyez donc la
divergence entre les ostéostracées
l'égaliaspidés et les poissons à
mâchoire qui sont là du fait que vous
avez maintenant tout ce beau monde qui
vient du Silurien inférieur chez
lacanthus est junks
faut que j'arrive à le dire View
shannonce
ne soyez jamais flemmard avec le nom de
vos genres lisez-les en entier et à
haute voix joue chez anostheus donc le
simple fait qu'il soit déjà là aussi le
rien naturellement pousse la racine
évolutive de tout ce beau monde alors
devicien donc on a déjà eu en fait la
divergence de tout ce beau monde à
l'époque et ça c'est très intéressant
c'est la première chose très
intéressante avec avec ça et donc ce qui
est là intéressant avec ce galet à
speeder donc déjà le fait que il
démontre par sa simple existence qu'il y
a une grande divergence une grande
diversification des poissons bien plutôt
qu'on ne se l'imaginer mais en plus
il nous montre d'où viennent les
nageoires pectorales parce que ce petit
galet à speeder il n'a pas de nageoire
pectorale certes mais comme les tissus
mousses sont préservés il a ces espèces
de crête sur le ventre ici vous voyez là
et qui sont bien représentés sur le
dessin interprétatif ici et qui sont
encore mieux représentés sur la
reconstitution 3D qu'il donne en
appendice je sais pas pourquoi ils ont
donné ça en appendice très honnêtement
mais voici la reconstitution 3D en
appendice donc voici les deux crêtes
voilà une crête ici et une crête là donc
ces deux crêtes ce sont pas des
nageoires encore mais les auteurs de cet
article font l'hypothèse que je trouve
raisonnable on les voit très bien
regardez ici là on a le le bouclier
céphalique c'est un autre spécimen on
voit le bouclier céphalique et on voit
une crête là une crête là et donc ces
deux crêtes ils font l'hypothèse que ce
sont les ancêtres des nageoires ce sont
les ancêtres des nageoires pectorales et
pelvienne d'ailleurs
alors d'où vient d'où vient cette
hypothèse tout simplement qu'en fait
là où c'est très intéressant c'est que
quand on voit ces deux crêtes c'est de
crête se joignent à l'arrière
et en se joignant à l'arrière c'est de
crête enfin déjà commençons par le début
ils ont fait des simulations des
simulations par ordinateur sur le modèle
en 3D que je vous ai montré ils ont fait
des simulations de comment ces crêtes
pouvaient aider ou pas à la flottabilité
de l'animal sécrète ont un effet sur la
flottabilité voilà c'est sécrète ont un
effet définitif sur la flottabilité
elles améliorent la flottabilité de
l'animal donc elles ont un effet positif
sur la nage donc ce sont des adaptations
sécrètes et là où c'est très intéressant
c'est qu'ils font l'hypothèse qu'en fait
c'est crête d'une part elles vont
devenir un jour les nageoires pectorales
de desostéostracés par différenciation
en fait elles vont pour l'instant ce ne
sont que des crêtes mais l'une une paire
de une paire de lobes va s'isoler à
l'avant pour former les nageoires
pectorales et une paire de lobes va
s'isoler à l'arrière pour former les
nageoires pelviennes
donc ça c'est l'hypothèse qu'ils font
donc on aurait un intermédiaire si vous
voulez entre l'absence de nageoire
totale des agnates et la présence de
nageoires chez les natostomes donc chez
les poissons à mâchoire donc ce galet à
speeder en fait il serait
l'intermédiaire entre les deux donc
absence de nageoire chez les agnaces
présence de nageoires chez les
Ostéostracés et les gnatostomes et donc
vous avez les galets aspider au milieu
qui eux n'auraient pas encore de
nageoire mais par contre ils auraient
des crêtes sur le ventre qui seraient
l'intermédiaire entre l'absence et la
présence de nageoires
et là c'est encore plus intéressant
c'est que c'est crête
là vous voyez ces crêtes c'est une paire
de crêtes en réalité il y a une crête de
chaque côté mais à l'arrière du fossile
ici elle se joignent pour former une
crête médiane on sait ce qu'ils ont
reconstitué ici sur leur modèle en 3D
vous voyez les crêtes là hop si vous
descendez vous descendez hop et elle se
joignent au milieu ici et ça ça veut
dire une chose ça veut dire que c'est
crête médiane enfin sécrète latérale
elles ont une origine médiane elles ont
une origine au milieu du corps donc
c'est en fait c'est pas en fait une
crête c'est une division c'est la
division d'une crête qui existait au
milieu du corps et ça pareil si vous
vous êtes jamais posé la question mais
d'où elles viennent ces nageoires parce
qu'au final vous avez une paire de
nageoires alors que quand vous regardez
terrasse fils par exemple quand vous
regardez une lampe proie vous voyez pas
de crête sur le côté vous voyez pas de
nageoires sur le côté vous voyez pas il
y a juste une nageoire au milieu à
l'arrière et
c'est tout et non et après quand vous
regardez terrassic vous avez une
nageoire à l'arrière et vous avez une
nageoire je crois sur le au moins une un
genre d'épines sur le milieu donc vous
avez une structure médiane mais vous
n'avez pas de structure latérale et donc
galet aspis vous montre comment d'une
structure médiane vous divisez cette
structure médiane pour former des
structures latérales donc d'aller à spi
en tout cas les auteurs de cet article
en se basant sur galetas font
l’hypothèse que les nageoires latérales
pectorales et pelviennes donc ont une
origine médiane c'est la division d'une
crête médiane qui a donné les
crêtes latérales qu'on voit chez galetas
qui vont elles-mêmes devenir les
nageoires
pectoral à l'avant et les nageoires
pelviennes à l'arrière donc tout ça ce
serait
issu d'une seule et même traite médiane
ça fait beaucoup d'hypothèses basées sur
une seule un seul enfin c'est pas un
seul fossile puisqu'ils en ont quand
même plus d'un de ces de ces tujies
comme il les appelle ils en ont quand
même plus qu'un seul de ces fossiles de
tujies aspices vividus c'est pour ça que
vous avez les photos en appendice c'est
parce que c'est pour vous illustrer tous
ces spécimens donc ils en ont quand même
plus d'un
donc ça fait beaucoup quand même
d'hypothèse basée sur une seule espèce
mais ça donne pour la première fois
l'idée de ce à quoi l'intermédiaire
entre l'absence de nageoire et la
présence de nageoire pouvait ressembler
donc dans l'absolu tu jaspice vividus
peut nous montrer ce à quoi ressemblait
en fait l'état de base de tous les
vertébrés à une certaine époque donc au
départ on aurait eu une crête médiane
cette crête médiane ce serait divisée en
V comme chez tijiaspis et elle aurait
déjà eu un avantage sur la flottabilité
à une époque où il y avait pas d'autres
poissons à nageoire ça aurait été un
avantage sélectif non négligeable on est
bien d'accord que là on parle de
l'ancêtre en commun de tigiaspis et
degnatostome et des ostéostracées donc
encore avant on est on est à leur
domicile quand je vous parle de cette
processus de division il a déjà eu lieu
chez ugia space donc ce processus de
division il aurait eu lieu à leur
deicien vous aurez le processus de
division qui va donner deux crêtes
latérales donc ce qu'on retrouve encore
chez etujiaspis aussi le rien et ces
deux crêtes latérales vont ensuite
complètement se séparer et ensuite une
partie à l'avant va s'isoler pour donner
les nageoires pectorales une partie à
l'arrière va s'isoler pour donner les
nageoires pelviennes et entre les deux
la crête va disparaître et c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec des gènes du développement ce qu'on
appelle les homéogènes qui sont
globalement les mêmes pour vos mains
enfin pour vos bras et pour vos jambes
les gènes du développement qui contrôle
vos bras et vos jambes sont quasiment
les mêmes
en tout cas ils ne fonctionnent pas du
tout indépendamment les uns des autres
c'est pour ça que c'est très difficile
de perdre les bras et pas les jambes par
exemple chez les par exemple chez
tyrannosaure on va prendre un exemple de
d'extrême réduction des bras c'est pour
ça que tyrannosaure il a encore des bras
c'est parce que si vous même si vous
vous servez pas de vos mains du tout
en réalité c'est très difficile de vous
débarrasser de vos mains d'un point de
vue du développement de biologie du
développement parce que les gènes qui
contrôlent la présence de vos mains et
de vos bras ce sont quasiment les mêmes
que ceux qui contrôlent la présence de
vos jambes et quand vous quand vous avez
des jambes comme celle de tyrannosaure
vous avez besoin de Gênes qui
fonctionnent
or si ces gènes en fonctionnement ont
comme en fonctionnant ont comme effets
secondaires d'aussi obligé des bras à
être là ben du coup vous finissez avec
des petits bras de merde
même si vous en avez pas besoin et que
la sélection naturelle a déjà
pas mal de choses dans le processus du
développement de vos bras vous finissez
quand même avec des petits bras de merde
voilà donc c'est parce que le
développement des jambes et le
développement des bras ne sont pas
indépendants du tout c'est très
difficile d'avoir l'un sans avoir
l'autre même quand bien même vous
n'aurez pas du tout besoin de l'un ou de
l'autre là on a quand même avec galet
donc avec ce tugie aspis on a quand même
un truc qui nous permet désormais de
fournir un scénario évolutif sur comment
on a transitionné d'animaux sans
nageoire avec des animaux à nageoir on a
c'est un intermédiaire structural
absolument grandiose gale et aspis il va
celui-là pour le coup il mérite sa
publication et il va rester dans les
annales ça c'est certain et on va en
reparler de galets de ces galets à
speeder on va en reparler parce que
maintenant on a il fournissent cette
intermédiaire entre pas de nageoire et
nageoires il fournissent un scénario
évolutif cohérent pour expliquer d'où
viennent les nageoires et pectorales et
pelvienne et il fournissent une
explication sur comment on est passé
d'animaux qui avaient que des nageoires
médianes à des nageoires latérales donc
là ça explique tellement de choses en
fait que que ça ça va être difficile de
contredire ce qui a été dit là dedans et
ça va bon bah ça va demander des
nouvelles découvertes évidemment on
demande pas que ce soit contredit au
contraire c'est encore mieux si c'est
pas contredit mais évidemment ça va être
très discuté ça va être très très
discuté parce qu'il y a d'autres modèles
qui ont été proposés pour le
développement des nageoires notamment le
modèle branchial qui est que les
nageoires seraient dérivés en fait des
branchies pas du tout du corps mais en
fait débranchies donc ça viendrait du
crâne les nageoires et ça expliquerait
de fait pourquoi chez les poissons parce
que vous regardez un poisson vous voyez
que les nageoires elles sont accrochées
ou elles sont accrochées à la tête
et ouais
les nageoires sont accrochés à la tête
chez les poissons et chez ça se voit
très très bien notamment chez les galets
à speeder par exemple enfin je sais pas
pardon chez les
pistes regardez toutes les
reconstructions de ces falas regardez
les fossiles de ces falaspi sous les
nageoires sont préservés les nageoires
elles sont accrochées là sur le bouclier
céphalique
donc il y a des gens qui ont proposé de
fait que les nageoires viendraient en
fait débranchies parce que c'est
l'endroit où on s'attend à trouver les
branches donc il y a pas mal de il y a
d'autres modèles que que le modèle
proposé ici contredit mais au moins ce
modèle est soutenu désormais par un
fossile qui représente une forme
intermédiaire et on va jamais se
plaindre de trouver des formes
intermédiaires et oui
voilà c'était pas léoniose je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
l'ancien et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]